[Musique]
et on passe tout de suite à notre page
culture on en parlait en début
d'émissions il y a quelques instants le
théâtre de 50 ans en Yvelines s'est
lancé dans de grands projets de
rénovation mais avant de parler de ces
travaux Lionel MACETA quelle est la
programmation de cette année et de
l'année
2022-2023 quelles sont les têtes
d'affiches il y en a beaucoup en fait
quelle est la programmation il y a plein
de spectacles et 180 représentations
donc ça fait beaucoup les têtes
d'affichage à venir il y en a pas mal il
y a Vichy Cohen qui ne va pas tarder il
y a le rappeur Youssoupha également
cette fin de semaine il y a un
Blanche-Neige très particulier il y a un
sacre du printemps très particulier
aussi il y a un chorégraphe hip-hop
brésilien Bruno Beltra qui arrive au
mois de décembre également donc la
programmation est particulièrement
fournie avec au programme de la danse de
la musique et du théâtre du théâtre de
50 ans en Yvelines c'est à dire que
c'est une scène pluridisciplinaire on
essaie de programmer tous les styles
toutes les esthétiques du spectacle
vivant alors on va parler un peu de la
fréquentation des salles de spectacle
car selon
[Musique]
une étude de Mediamétrie en tout cas 48%
des Français ne vont plus au théâtre et
28 % ils vont moins souvent alors est-ce
que c'est le cas sur la scène nationale
depuis le début de la saison on est à 80
aux alentours de 90% de toute
fréquentation c'est à dire qu'on a un
taux de fréquentation qui est supérieur
à la saison
2018-2019 c'est à dire la saison juste
avant le covid donc c'est un rebond qui
est très impressionnant je veux pas dire
qu'il nous surprend parce qu'on a tout
fait pour y compris pendant cette
période de crise sanitaire on a été
vraiment toutes les équipes ont été très
présentes sur le terrain on a changé
modifier nos moyens de communication nos
outils de communication
et l'année dernière était une année de
reprise où on était aux alentours de 70%
de taux de fréquentation et la dès cette
année alors avec des habitudes qui
changent un tout petit peu dans les
réservations
beaucoup plus de réservations de
dernière minute mais au final la
quasi-totalité des salles sont quasiment
pleines donc on est très heureux de
voilà d'avoir fait et poursuivi ces
efforts pendant ces deux années et demi
qui était fort compliquées
de la crise sanitaire est-ce que
l'inflation aussi qu'on connaît
actuellement ne n'empêche pas les gens
de venir au théâtre pour l'instant ça se
ressent pas mais ça va se ressentir un
moment ou un autre et puis l'inflation
va pas se ressentir uniquement dans le
fait de sortir de ne pas sortir au
théâtre elle va se ressentir dans nous
les contrats que nous signons les
prestations que nous avons dans
certainement les subventions que nous
percevons donc ça touche quelque chose
de beaucoup plus large qu'uniquement la
sortie des spectateurs mais pour
l'instant et grâce subventions que l'on
perçoit du département de
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin bien
entendu de la région et de l'état on
peut maintenir des prix des prix des
tarifs bas ce qui permet à beaucoup de
gens de sortir et puis on a aussi des
tarifs qui sont très spécifiques en
fonction des ressources des personnes
des situations des personnes qui
viennent nous vous vous engagez à rester
accessible finalement
c'est notre mission et alors en
septembre vous allez lancer des grands
travaux on en parlait un tout petit peu
en début d'émission qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que ça va concerner est-ce que
vous pouvez nous le redire plus en
détail oui en fait c'est pas nous qui
allons lancer c'est l'agglomération
puisque c'est l'agglomération de 50 ans
en Yvelines qui est propriétaire du
bâtiment l'agglomération et les
partenaires financiers de ce projet
lorsque le théâtre a été construit en
1987 ans il a ouvert en septembre 93 il
était finalement assez différent des
plans qu'avaient conçu l'architecte
initial Stanislas Fisher puisqu'il
devait y avoir sur le ce qui est
l'actuel parvis il devait y avoir un
espace par restaurant il devait y avoir
également une réserve des ateliers de
décor à l'arrière du bâtiment ça n'a pas
été fait pour des raisons de coûts et de
maîtrise des coûts que l'on peut
comprendre et aujourd'hui c'est ces
éléments manquent et avec
l'agglomération
l'agglomération qui est sur une sur une
réflexion plus qu'une réflexion sur la
difficile de qualification de ce qu'on
appelle l'hyper centre de 51 en Yvelines
la question qui s'est posée c'était
quelle est la place d'un théâtre qui est
au bout de l'avenue du centre c'est à
dire qu'il est visible à 2 km de
l'endroit où il se trouve qui est dans
un lieu hyper passant et comment est-ce
qu'on peut travailler sur le théâtre
pour en faire un élément de lien non pas
un bâtiment intimidant c'est pas c'est
pas un jugement sur l'architecture de ce
bâtiment moi que je que j'aime beaucoup
c'est un bâtiment mais c'est un bâtiment
voilà imposant ou intimidant comment
est-ce qu'on peut faire un lien entre ce
bâtiment et cette place qui va être
requalifiée où il y aura un peu plus de
place pour les pour les piétons et en
fait le projet qui a été choisi par par
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin et ses
partenaires c'est un projet qui est un
trait d'union qui fait du parvient
véritable trait d'union entre le
bâtiment et la place parvis qui va être
couvert de façon extrêmement élégante et
qui va pouvoir accueillir un restaurant
assis une brasserie où on pourra
grignoter un peu plus rapidement un
espace de détente et bien entendu la
billetterie qui sera aussi un espace de
une ambulation qui redonnera l'intérieur
du théâtre c'est ses qualités qui fera
du théâtre une véritable balade
architecturale donc un restaurant qui
sera ouvert et une brasserie qui sont
ouvert à midi et soir l'idée c'est que
le théâtre vive au quotidien
c'est ce lieu plus convivial ben oui de
lui donner des attributs des qualités
qui n'a pas entièrement aujourd'hui qui
est en charge de ces travaux
l'agglomération et les partenaires ont
choisi une jeune agence qui s'appelle
l'agence Fagard Fontana et les ningets
qui étaient sur les 68 agences qui ont
postuler qui faisaient vraiment partie
des outsiders et qui est certainement
celle et c'est certes pour ça qu'elle a
été qu'elle a été retenue qui qui tenait
compte à la fois de l'existant et des
marqueurs du bâtiment du grand bâtiment
actuel c'est à dire l'arche la verrière
la façade de façon Auguste Perret qui
avait des participation écologique et
qui avait des préoccupations de
comment dire de de wed de possibilité de
transformer d'utiliser de manière
différente ce grand espace qui est créé
que les archives ont baptisé un grand
lobby urbain donc cet espace peut être
utilisé de plein de façons différentes
donc toutes les qualités étaient là pour
que ce projet soit retenu y compris des
questions de coûts et de facilité de
mise en oeuvre de ces travaux justement
le coup vous le savez rapidement
de 8 millions d'euros avec une un
soutien des partenaires à hauteur de 5
millions d'euros dans 3 millions d'euros
qui restent à la charge de
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines et
bien merci Lionel masetta
avec nous je le rappelle vous êtes le
directeur du Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on part à la
découverte d'une exposition maintenant à
la médiathèque Aimé Césaire de la
verrière totem c'est l'oeuvre de des
habitants des douze communes de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines le reportage
réalisé par gré et Régine ralech lancée
de dés attribution d'une boîte sélection
de matériaux et place à la création ce
sont les règles que c'était fixées
Agathe bezot pour réaliser l'exposition
ludique le processus de création se
faisait autour du jeu et tous les
Yvelines étaient invités à participer
[Musique]
en fait quand les médiathèques ont
sollicité sur ce projet donc dont la
donc le brief c'était de faire une
action collective qui relie les publics
j'ai proposé cette notion de totem parce
que ça m'intéressait d'être dans la
construction de l'amitié et il n'y a pas
besoin entre guillemets d'être habité
ici ou ailleurs on a on est relié par
un lien un peu indéfectible qui est
invisible mais qui est là entre humains
en fait et je trouve que c'est ce
qu'elle les met en valeur et en lumière
c'est en juillet dernier kayad bezot a
démarré son processus de création à
partir d'ateliers de rue l'exposition a
pris forme dans plusieurs villes de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines notre action
culturelle au sein de l'agglomération
c'est entre autres de créer du lien
entre les habitants de créer du lien
entre les villes et de faire corps pour
créer cette identité de territoire à
laquelle nous sommes attachés des copies
de l'oeuvre finale seront exposées dans
chaque médiathèque de l'agglomération et
ce de manière définitive
l'association argavure faite ses 40 ans
cette année ce sera le week-end du 3 et
du 4 décembre prochain pour en parler
Catherine delmel présidente de
l'association Art gravure et Chantal
Roumy secrétaire de l'association alors
qu'est-ce que vous avez prévu pour fêter
ces 40 ans alors pour ces 40 ans on a
bien sûr notre gâteau avec les carottes
bougies dont je parlais tout à l'heure
mais nous avons une exposition sur nos
murs de gravures qui sont de formats 40
sur 40 le chiffre 40 va revenir de
manière constante cette exposition elle
va présenter des gravures de toutes
sortes de techniques et les graveurs
seront là présent pour répondre aux
questions des visiteurs pour leur
expliquer il y aura aussi des
démonstrations ce qui pourra encore
mieux faire comprendre la technique de
la gravure il y a aussi des livres
d'artistes des objets en tout genre des
dis ça que des tops
des cartes des créations comme des pin's
des boîtes vous pourrez aussi également
une tombola oui voilà il y aura cet
animation de ton volant ça c'est pour
faire
animer il y aura 40 gravures alors c'est
40 gravures à gagner elles seront
toujours de 40 sur 40 mais dans les deux
jours il y en a il y en aura 20 un jour
et 20 un autre jour et puis il y aura un
buffet qui sera constamment présent pour
accueillir nos autres voilà il y a
dimanche un petit intermède musical
violon et percussions enfin bref on
espère une ambiance familiale tout
autour de cette technique qu'elle a
gravure Gabriel 40 ans d'anniversaire
c'est un succès avec toutes ces années
qu'est-ce qui fait le succès de Dark
gravure finalement alors le succès
d'agravure s'est construit petit à petit
au fur et à mesure de se faire connaître
dans les différentes communes de
l'agglomération on a travaillé dans
plein d'exposition je projet voilà on a
eu de 16 de vouloir se faire connaître
cette pratique rare nous sommes les
seuls dans toute l'agglomération et donc
depuis
1982 ou cette cette association a été
créée par Colette kunnen on a eu de 16
voilà de de développer cette cette
pratique de faire connaître cette
pratique et dans nos statuts il y avait
la règle d'or c'était que qu'il y ait
justement un enseignement donc des cours
dispensés et ils sont dispensés donc
depuis 40 ans par nos professeurs il y
en a eu trois en tout et aujourd'hui
c'est donc Valérie Loiseau qui fait qui
s'occupe donc de quatre cours
dans la semaine un le soir comme ça
c'est assez c'est relativement nouveau
pour permettre à aux gens qui
travaillent pour pouvoir venir le soir
c'est une manière justement de faire
perpétuer le savoir autour de la gravure
certainement et puis nous avons aussi un
beau patrimoine avec nos machines nos on
a quatre presses pour la taille douce on
a une presse pour le bois
disons que on a aussi une presse mais
bon que l'on utilise moins pour la
typographie on a aussi tous les
caractères bref c'est une je veux dire
c'est un atelier qui a vraiment tout
pour travailler la gravure alors que ce
soit les techniques plus anciennes que
ce soit les techniques plus modernes on
sent que vous êtes passionné par la
gravure pourquoi cette passion
en fait on a découvert quand on la
pratique on découvre des beaucoup
beaucoup de techniques différentes et
finalement et qu'on arrive aussi à
combiner et puis évidemment c'est aussi
le fait que ce soit convivial qu'on se
retrouve ensemble à créer et ça c'est
toujours extrêmement agréable et puis on
apprend toujours parce que il y a de
nombreuses techniques entre les voilà
les techniques anciennes et puis jusque
aux techniques contemporaines voilà qui
qui se développe même encore aujourd'hui
donc c'est vraiment passionnant en fait
vous avez des matériaux très différents
vous passez du cuivre vous passez aux
zinc et puis tout d'un coup vous pouvez
prendre du plexiglas vous pouvez prendre
du carton vous pouvez prendre du bois
tout ça sert comme support à la gravure
donc vous avez vraiment une palette très
très riche de techniques je dirais
presque que c'est
jubilatoire d'avoir tout ça devant soi
et de pouvoir créer alors agravure faite
c'est 40 ans est-ce que il y a quelque
chose qui vous rend fier
particulièrement en tant que présidente
en tant que secrétaire de cette
association oui moi ce qui nous rend
fier c'est que on a quand même eu pas
mal d'obstacles à surmonter avec le
covid la récemment parce qu'on a dû
fermer c'était pas évident on peut
remercier nos adhérents aussi parce
qu'ils ont contribué quand même à nous
aider à survivre on va dire combien
d'adhérents environ une quarantaine
et oui alors on est fier parce que on se
donne beaucoup de mal pour se faire
connaître pour rayonner dans toute la
l'agglomération donc depuis ces 40 ans
avec toutes les expositions que nous
faisons pour chaque année on a des
projets chaque année donc c'est quand
même beaucoup de travail parce que je
rappelle que nous sommes tous bénévoles
par notre professeur qu'elle salarié
mais donc voilà on fait des une
exposition pratiquement chaque année
dans dans toutes les villes de
l'agglomération à Montigny à plaisir à
Guyancourt enfin etc et aussi à
l'extérieur on a même fait des échanges
avec les États-Unis et l'Italie et aussi
inter association en ayant fait venir
aussi des des relieurs parce que
reliures et livres d'artistes voilà ça
ça pouvait marcher ensemble donc voilà
beaucoup d'échanges et beaucoup de
on est fier aussi parce que comme vous
le disiez tout à l'heure on a un
patrimoine entre les mains qui sait
effectivement donné depuis 1982 bon
alors avec la succession des professeurs
successions des présidentes mais ce
matériel qui est
une grande j'allais dire d'une grande
qualité on a des presses qui datent
un patrimoine qui est on en est fier
voilà on a envie de en prendre vraiment
soin merci Catherine delmel et Chantal
Remy d'être venu en plateau pour en
parler avec nous si vous êtes intéressé
rendez vous les trois et quatre décembre
prochain à la zone d'activités des 4
heures et si vous êtes amateur de VF
quand vous regardez un film vous avez
sûrement déjà entendu sa voix Donald
Reignoux et dans le métier depuis 30 ans
parmi sa vaxographie Titeuf Andre
Garfield ou encore Jess et zenberg et
chose que vous ne savez peut-être pas
Donald Reignoux a grandi à Bois-d'Arcy
il est l'invité de Mélanie poquet dans
un nouveau numéro du
vyby on regarde un extrait
je suis tombé dans le petit par une un
petit coup de pouce mais j'ai entretenu
cette chance et mais j'en faisais pas
une un objectif et le doublage avait pas
la la
visibilité qui a maintenant
mais c'est vrai que c'est cool ça
parcourt atypique et puis par le chant
et pourtant vous chantez pas souvent je
crois que ça parle la Reine des Neiges 2
c'est vrai que c'est pas mon fort le
chant ça me permet d'avoir des rôles
souvent chez Disney parler chanter mais
je suis pas proprement parler chanteur
parce que je suis pas je n'entends pas
les capacités donc en comédien je suis
capable de proposer 10 versions
différentes par prise et qui ont rien à
voir en change je suis capable de
chanter juste ça s'arrêtera là donc je
peux pas interpréter plus que ça on est
arrivé presque à aujourd'hui mais au
début vous dites des chants des voix des
semelles et le premier rôle vous tapez
quand même très fort Andy Toy Story
c'est pas le premier rôle mais en tout
cas c'est le premier vrai rôle qui m'a
lancé effectivement
c'est vrai que le bouche-à-oreille a
presque film là a été énorme et voilà vu
qu'on est dans les Yvelines j'ai été au
collège Mozart et j'ai arrêté le collège
traditionnel le jour de l'avant-première
pour partir en cours par correspondance
et il m'avait dit que c'était pas un
métier de faire comédien donc
je peux comprendre parce que c'est un
métier qui fait peur c'est un métier qui
est qui est précaire moi je m'en sors
très bien et qui est très hasardeux mais
c'est vrai que on peut très vite avoir
des des longs moments sans travailler
donc je peux je peux comprendre qu'ils
étaient inquiet mais je suis content
d'avoir eu raison de croire en moi c'est
la fin de notre page culture retour sur
l'actualité dans le département
[Musique]